[Music]
well pretty much since the day joe biden
got inaugurated you've been hearing in
the media every day that the state of
florida is a coveted hotspot virtually
every person in the state has died of
the coronavirus
but suddenly you're not hearing that
anymore why is that well because the
numbers are too stark to deny
in the last seven days florida has
averaged few
fewer coveted cases per capita than
virtually any other state in the united
states it ranks 48 out of 50. now the
governor of the state ron desantis has
announced a special legislative session
to ban kovitz 19 related vaccine
mandates not just by the state but by
businesses
throughout the state of florida the
governor of florida ron sanchez joins us
now
governor thanks so much for coming on so
if you would explain what this would
mean and why you're doing it
tucker
over more than anything this is an
individual choice your livelihood should
not be dependent on whether you get a
coveted shot much less in the future if
these mandates take hold whether you get
your yearly booster or booster every six
months or whatever they're going to make
you do
this is a personal decision number two
what biden's doing is unconstitutional
and we have a responsibility as a state
to fight back against federal overreach
but then number three this is not good
for the economy this is just bad policy
you have a lot of businesses that
actually need people particularly in
health care and what you're going to
give people walking papers in the middle
of this so i think it's bad all around
and i think that yes we're going to be
doing litigation against the byte
administration which is important but we
also need to do legislation to provide
protections for folks in florida and
i'll tell you tucker yes biden's doing
mandates and i disagree with that i
think we all do
but there are businesses that are doing
this on their own even apart from the
mandates and these are employees of
theirs that have been working throughout
this whole pandemic and now they're
being told you get your walking papers
that is not a free choice you know
tucker we had a nurse today at our event
she has already had covid and she's
pregnant right now and so she says i
think this is something that i don't
want to do how is that something that
you're going to deprive her of a right
to make a living based on that very
reasonable decision
so the what the white house is very
focused on you and on your state and
this is the centerpiece of their
domestic agenda vaccine mandates this is
the whole thing it's what they care
about most so if you openly defy them i
mean are you expecting them to hit back
try to choke off federal health care
money to the state or do you expect some
kind of confrontation with the bide
administration
well i'm sure they're going to do
whatever they can tucker over the summer
when we had delta hit i started a
monoclonal antibody program because
people were being admitted to the
hospital without getting early treatment
so since we put that program in our
daily admissions have gone down about 90
percent well as we were doing that biden
tried to cut off the supply to florida
because this was working and so i
imagine they're definitely going to do
something
to try to hit back but at the end of the
day do you think people do you want to
protect people's jobs or do you not and
i'm going to be on the side of
protecting people's jobs and if joe
biden wants to be on the side of causing
people to lose their job well
then we'll let him do that and we'll
fight the good fight yeah because he
knows more about medicine than nurses
and doctors it's like lunacy um so the
supply chain crisis is a real crisis i
think a year ago it cost
three grand to move a container from
asia to the east coast united states is
down 20 grand so this is affecting every
part of the u.s economy you say you have
a solution or a part solution to this
what is it
so we have capacity at all of our ports
remember tucker they made a big deal
about la gonna start doing 24 7. we
always do 24 7 in florida we've got
capacity and all of our ports can offer
these businesses good incentives if they
reroute their ships we've already had
some ships rerouted we expect to have
more but if you're going to sit off the
coast for days on end you might as well
just bring it to florida we've got great
logistics on the ground that can get it
to market and we're happy to be able to
step up because there are empty shelves
this is driving inflation this is going
to cause shortages we already see
shortages it's going to affect the
christmas season so i think florida can
be part of the solution here
the more florida acts like a country
right now i think the better for all of
us my personal view governor understand
this i appreciate your coming on thank
you so much
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else